we're now doing over conservation in
which Gryphon is shown to different
amounts of juice so he and tell that one
has more one has less and then we poured
these into containers that are rigged so
they have a false bottom so the smaller
quantity still looks at the same level
as the bigger quantity and now
supposedly he can't tell just by looking
at these two cups which one has more and
he's then asked to choose one of the
cups and he wants the one that has more
so if he's able to pay attention to what
I'm doing and showing him previously and
conserve that information about that
quantity that is higher and apply that
even though he now can no longer see
which one is higher that is evidence of
conservation and that's what we're
trying to do right now